hello everybody my name is markiplier
and today I'm gonna show you the most
ridiculous game of risk of rain to I've
ever played I'm not good at this game at
least I don't think I am and I know this
probably won't be too impressive for you
guys who have been like playing or asked
rain to forever and ever but it's
getting so hectic that it's starting to
slow my computer down so I want to
record it for posterity alone to prove
that I actually accomplished something
so I'm playing the new character I don't
know what the name of it is just plant
robot thing and things have gotten so
like incredibly overpowered on my n I'm
stupidly overpowered at this point I've
gotten some close scrapes I've even
almost died once I had an item that
saved my life but as you can see at the
top if you don't know that what this
game is about I have a lot of items I've
been through 25 levels this is the 25th
and everything is way different than any
other time you've seen me play this game
ever I just started playing this earlier
today and I kind of like kept playing
I'm not even like trying that hard right
now because honestly I don't need to
it's just a lot of numbers a lot of
things a lot of numbers a lots happening
the only danger I got to worry about is
those green spikes because they stopped
me from healing and the fact that I can
heal is the only reason that I'm staying
alive so much I have so I'll try to like
detail exactly what I have that's making
this overpowered but I don't know if
I'll be able to do that and concentrate
so if I die straight up oh I'll blame
you and it'll be your fault entirely
so yeah number one this is the new
character that is based on healing a lot
of healing oh yeah I'm also I broke the
game in terms of like mobility because
watch this is what this character can do
I can just that's uh I'm not using any
cheats or anything this is just like
I've gotten enough items that that's
just when I do my movement ability
that's just what I do also ignore my my
equipment I accidentally touched an
equipment drone and I don't have what I
should have and that was the most recent
thing I picked up yes III know it's
redundant and I don't even need to fly
when I can fly already oh yes so pretty
much there's only bosses now everything
is a boss and everything is like an
elite boss as well it's not just normal
bosses quick and fast breakdown I am
rocking a suite
bunch of artifact items one of which
makes any / healing turn into a
temporary shield which is that gold bar
over my health which just means it's up
all the time cuz that's all my character
does is he'll basically I've got some
cooldown reduction I've got some stuff
that makes ghost copies of anything I
kill including bosses I've got something
that steals the ability of enemies and
that includes like if if they have a
shield on at any time I'll steal their
shield and various abilities that they
can do that make me even more
overpowered every time I touch open
something it shoots out lots of
fireworks that hit with the force of
like a rocket so that that all those
little dings that's that's that going
off those are my ghosts actually those
are under my control so they shouldn't
be trying to kill me oh where you
swatting there big guy yeah just this
it's real weird things appear really
really a lot quick as you can see in the
top right it's been hahaha for a long
time now ever since I had that close
scrape I I really haven't had any
problems thus far so I've just been
trying to go for more firepower just to
kill things quicker I wish I could find
an enchantment thing my other
enchantment was actually a new item that
helps locate things which is very useful
for scouring a lot of items I think the
one reason I've been able to get as far
as I have is just because I've been able
to get all the items in every level
every time with that artifact that
searches for them but yeah I just say
that's that's that's pretty much it as I
mean there's obviously not pretty much
it because if you look in the top middle
you'll see that I clearly have a
bajillion more things that are probably
worth mentioning but I can't even be
bothered to think about it right now
cuz of everything that's happening in
front of me so yeah I'm just gonna keep
going I'm gonna see how far I get I'm
level 41 I don't know if there's a max
level I don't know if there's a max
anything I don't know if it's just like
actually built to go on forever I mean
it's got to get to a point where like
diminishing returns right there's got to
be a point where I just can't win well I
kind of crossed a threshold where things
got a lot easier before they got harder
but I don't know I still have to be a
little cautious I mean I I grew too
accustomed to the thing that helped me
find items now I can't find them on my
own when it when I trigger a base a boss
by the way the bosses die super fast but
it makes everything else really
I don't know why or what happens when it
happens like that but it sure dude it
sure do and then the bosses are dead but
then everything else gets nightmare mode
like they just boss fight ain't over so
I'm just gonna just good cool
hey look at me it's all I'll update you
if any happenings happen but just in the
meantime just enjoy this nice ASMR of
risk of whoa that doesn't look good oh
I'm out of here see ya see ya see ya see
you later my good oh [ __ ]
nope not today not today woah that's a
big ball whoa what the hell hey what are
you doing up here hey that's a lot of
boss Joe there's so many boss I gotta
get back in this zone it is nice when I
got boss level minions working for me
I don't exactly know how much damage
they do compared to me but goddamn it it
still feels nice missed this one I know
I probably missed other stuff like that
was open but I didn't pick it up but
whatever
alright ah guess we're all done here
gonna go now goodbye I know I've missed
things but alas c'est la vie I don't
have my computer that tells me where
everything is so I just got a guess
hi goodbye who the gold gun well I do
have too much gold so also I have I have
28 teddy bears so you can imagine you
could just imagine their radar yay radar
see now I can see everything everything
shows up as like an exclamation mark or
a question marker I don't know what
things are you did I get you all bundle
of fireworks and as if I needed more of
those I'm so fast that if I hit a speed
bump or anything in the road like uneven
terrain I just rock it up into the sky
at like super speed so it'll catch me
off-guard I'm trying to run away from
something or I'm trying to get somewhere
and then just
oh my god not another Hoopoe feather
I've got so many who feather means did I
get an extra jump but I've got seven of
them so I get seven jumps I don't need
seven jumps alright and then yet another
boss and then the boss dies real quick
so the thing about this character is
it's supposed to be a balance of damage
and healing because even a lot of your
big attacks on this character hurt
yourself so you take damage so you're
not supposed to be able to do these self
damaging attacks too much but I can
basically spam them because I heal so
unbelievably a lot I think I've broken I
think this is broken like I hate to say
it cuz I don't know I have no frame of
reference for this but this feels like I
shouldn't be able to just do that it
feels like I shouldn't be able to do
this number one but I can so I don't
know oh no you turn into a ghost what
are you gonna do about your existence
now you serve me look at me I am boss
now I am captain boss I [ __ ] that
reference up now I owned it
I gotta have confidence myself I
destroyed that reference well I mean
yeah okay I destroyed that reference but
in a good way I'm like a badass way and
I like yeah I made it my own kind of
thing way yeah Garbowsky
and I win and I've got another quail dad
sit durable that just makes us so I jump
forward when I sprint oh this is a new
map that they got in this latest update
that brought this character in here I
can't go back to like level one again
after this because I'm so used to going
at lightning speed now the thing is like
I'm only gonna get faster as as time
goes on here at the longer I play if I
stay alive I'm only gonna get faster and
I don't know if there's gonna reach a
point where the games not gonna be able
to handle it if like I'm gonna just fly
off the edge of the map every time I try
to move like I'm no longer gonna be able
to make subtle movements I don't know I
don't know where the line is okay these
guys are actually dangerous that
nevermind they're dead so this is just
kind of my life now I just go around I
grab whatever is there I run away with
it I kill everything in sight and I just
keep leveling up
that's pretty much my life now and I've
only been playing for like over three
hours on this which isn't that long
considering games so I feel like
something's got to give eventually
something just got again so you would I
love the radar though love this radar
well that's a lot of ball uses there's
so many bosses there's so wait what the
hell that's so many jarheads that's so
many of those dudes oh my god I got if I
actually took a lot of damage I'd be
worried about that and they're ghosts
now you serve me oh wow yeah this is
what I meant by my computer starts
lagging a a lot of a lot of things
happening yep the slowdown is real here
more fireworks why not also I don't know
what's doing it but things are dying
when I'm not even doing anything I don't
know why I do I've gotten to the point
where I actually don't know all the [ __ ]
that I have on me because I've been
playing this one so long and I picked so
many things up and I've I obviously
can't read anything because there's so
much chaos happening on the screen but
yeah YouTube's gonna have a field day
with this one there's gonna look like
garbage a lockbox I was never able to
find lock boxes before oh I get to cheat
death again hey that's what I used up
already
I used that on earlier like if I if I
didn't have that item I would never get
to this point where I am right now which
is with everything being broken like
this Oh a Sat it's more clay Striders
teapots you're a big teapot I see your
spout now show me your handle well
they're all dead
I mean honestly like this game has just
turned into frantic clicking jumping
around moving too fast and collecting
loot I don't really have to worry about
death anymore
cuz the thing is like as my character
gets stronger at the faster I shoot the
more I heal because my main shoot is
what heals me and my my other ability
also heals me and that helps me too
because it routes the enemies in place
so they stay still they don't move I
dance around him I heal that's all there
is - yeah
pretty fun right guys I can't even tell
what's happening what has happened where
am I whose ass am i inside of where is
everything okay it's time to go I think
oh boy another waxed quail here we go
there see you guys and and it just says
ha ha ha forever I'm pretty sure oh yes
please challenge of the mountain today
I can't where is the challenge of the
bike you this is my big annoyance and
literally the only noise that happens I
can't see anything there it is I invite
the challenge of the mountain I sure do
yeah I already have like 6 million gold
I've only just started this level here
and like I used to have like a damaging
equipment but I've found that being able
to know where everything is is so much
more valuable so long as you can still
kill which apparently I can I'm trying
to did that open I don't know if it
opened I think I got it I can't tell I
just I don't know anymore this is the
kind of [ __ ] that will destroy my eyes
like just trying to keep track of all
this garbage here on the screen all at
once like there's nothing like my brain
cannot keep up with this also like there
are so many more things to open and
obtain then I ever thought there were in
this game and in these levels like you I
I thought I was pretty thorough about
loot before but once I got this like it
made me realize how much I've missed
every time I've played through here just
like speeding through trying to get by
nah
the only way to win is to get absolutely
everything especially this thing which
is a free red artifact every time
reduces the cooldown is great as if I
needed to go faster whoa whoa oh my god
I'm gonna get the high ground
I know equipment for you no no no you
diner drones are worthless at this point
by the way they die instantaneously they
don't scale with your health for some
reason so they just die so don't even
bother with drones they ain't worth it
they're just gonna leave you by
and one thing I happen to be enabled
their mystery box I never would have
been able to guess that was there how
would I've seen that okay red whip okay
got it
great and I move on now oh my god can I
can I just offer can I just use the
shrine please as soon as I stop as soon
as I stop it's chaos thank you
I got brilliant behemoth I already have
that I think no wait do i oh if I've
never gotten brilliant behemoth oh [ __ ]
well now I do all my attacks explode I
thought they did that already huh I
guess I didn't have that well looks like
I do more damage than ever now great oh
my god oh my god oh my god let me out
let me out
good thing I got so many teddy bears how
have I missed
yeah I've opened this meow well [ __ ]
I've opened so many things there's still
this many things to find it's absurd
oh yes another challenge of the mountain
you bet your sweet butt took us I want
that med bot yeah you'll you'll probably
die soon oh my god just leave me alone
you're gonna die anyway just leave me
alone enjoy your existence okay getting
close to everything only things left for
like artifacts that I've opened and left
on the ground I think okay I think I'm
good I'm gonna go open the boss now it's
a challenge of the mountains so it's got
to be real tough right yeah of course
alright tough tough tough very tough and
dead okay good
oh wait no a little more a little more
and dead okay they're all dead good that
was real tough really really tough guys
oh you fuel cells yes I was I have not
been able to get fuel cells this whole
time
I don't know why now I can switch to a
damaged one if I want it lay magma worms
why are you all here you kind of all
suck easy come easy go
oh hey malachite lizards the malachite
dudes are actually kind of tough and
there they go
and almost done here we go three two one
kaboom
good job guys you'll get me next time I
believe in you I mean I don't believe in
you I've been through this so many times
now and no one has even come close to
killing me
and there you have it back at the
beginning again one good loop yeah I I
don't know I don't know where to uh
where to go with this so I think I'm
gonna end this here because I don't
think there's gonna be anything that's
changing I just wanted to show you guys
this because it is just fascinating to
me that I was able to get to this point
and again this might be nothing special
this might be perfectly fine everyone
everyone wants to go home might be like
I could do that man glued my ass blind
boy I can do you do that with both arms
tied but anyway you guys probably could
do that but I don't usually do this kind
of thing with what with the success and
seeming like I've got some kind of skill
and whatnot so you know it's kind of
cool sometimes I can't see it it's so
bright oh there we go
that's what I mean hit a speed bump and
I go flying oh wait is that the
headdress thing oh I could do that a few
times uh one of the reasons why my
attack speed is so ridiculously high is
because of this thing I crit every shot
everything crits all the time so if I
did this I would have nothing but at Dax
speed
I have 17 of those this is 18 let's make
it an even 20 why not
Tamura the more I attack the more I heal
alright 20 is good 20 is good little
leave it at 20 what the hell I don't
know if the developers intended this cup
man they blow up so Wessel it wet aliy
wesley they they blow up so goofily I
got the goopy blows all right here we go
all I see is red and white and blue I'm
in love America like what else could
they throw at me
what else could they possibly throw at
me they're already throwing the mutated
versions of the bosses in packs of 10
like there's literally nothing else they
could throw at me at the
point that would hurt me right unless
they got some secret bosses up their
sleeves I don't know man they just melt
everything I guess we're done all right
moving on yeah every time I leave as
fireworks as far as the eye could see
yeah so uh I legitimately don't know I
like guys what do I do
I'm uh I'm like one pinch man I got too
strong I never knew what would happen
when I got too strong whoa never mind
they're dead every time I turn around
I'm like that's a lot my brain is like
oh it's a lot of people I'm like oh wait
no they're nothing they they die okay
gonna go for the boss I like I said I
don't know what else to do
I don't I know that there's gotta be
like a 999 stage run from somebody
that's played for days and days and days
but for me this is amazing what I'm able
to do here so uh yeah you know I'm just
gonna take it for what it is and just
pat myself on the back at completely
making the game absolutely unfelt at the
game is that there's a challenges
permanent is like oh if I die all my
progress but now it's like well I guess
the risk of death is there so what point
is the progress but whatever you know
I'm kind of still going it's so kind of
fun it's jumping around everybody dying
I guess Oh
did everyone give up already there's no
save in this game by the way there's no
save so if I want to keep playing this I
just kind of like alt-tab and hope my
computer doesn't crash you know like
old-school stylez leaving the console on
when it doesn't have a save like old
Super Nintendo things that didn't have
saves okay sometimes actually I did that
as as late as high school so huh with
Xboxes and whatnot PlayStation I
remember leaving that console on for
some reason all right I guess I move on
with my 80 billion health your fist
tried to fist me
what does that it was that it normal was
that a normal enemy not a not a boss
what what are you thinking are they
crazy get out of here with that what are
you doing it's like a child just
wandered into a war zone get out of here
oh my god wait have there been like
normal enemies underneath the feet of
these giant bosses this whole time
because if if so I feel bad because I am
I have not even noticed that they do so
my biggest threat right now is me
running off a cliff did a lockbox just
open up and give me a rusted key I swear
that's just what happened you need a
rusted key to open a lockbox so it's
giving you the thing that you it's
giving you your key back basically
that's what happened I twisted the lock
and it turned to dust and all that was
left was the key I used to open it great
it's like a stick key in here and then
you open the lid and it's the key you
just dropped in Gregg thank you very
useful fun trick I like it yeah never
talk to me again we I don't need no
bridge bridges or flus hey you're just
in time out all by yourself and I came
over to say haha and goodbye I could add
to the chaos wait wait I just realized
what this was this is another new item
it's called the backup basically you can
summon drones there we go there we go
there we go there we go there we go
there we go there we go go drones go oh
that is some kind of amazing I love that
I love that they don't last forever
they're not permanent drones but man
that is that is hilarious what if I put
that's an equipment drone right there
what if I put the radio in with the
equipment drone and then it's a drone
that summons drones yes that'll work
right yeah so they have these it's dead
it just flew up god dammit god god damn
I tell you drones just can't last they
physically cannot last at this level
they just can't it just won't
last you might as well not have them
because they're just gonna die I'm just
gonna go for okay all right cool good I
went for it I think I can't tell it's so
bright and you're dead okay great what
is that a hundred and forty million gold
140 million that's not enough gold it's
just nonsense on screen it there's
nothing to be discerned from any of this
hey a celestial portal I could destroy
my character no not gonna gonna keep
going I'm having a great time stage 32
baby I already got the achievement for
20 stages I don't know if there's
another one after that I think that
maybe there would be we shall see I just
like how many more items could I
possibly get like what is there is there
a limit I've got nothing left to say is
the thing I've got nothing left to say
I've said everything I could feasibly
possibly say in regards to the insanity
that's in front of you and it's still
going like it just it it don't stop so
what else do I do what did I just do
wait what what did I do
what was that seemed different than
anything I've seen before it was
probably something special and very
important and it would be really cool to
know what it was but there's no way I
could tell because the too much was
happening on screen so I'll just I'll
never know I'll just die without knowing
I'm lost I'm lost
it's as if I can't see anything I'm lost
oh hell yeah what did I get
aigis I don't know what that is I wish I
could see the healing past full grants
through temporary barrier oh I have two
of those now good very good now I'm even
more indestructible aha
there you are finally okay what have you
got what do we get what do we get
ooh another happy mask more go screamed
oh great you know let's just go for this
sooner we started the sooner we can get
it over with
alright who's up who's up I can't see
who's up because I can't see anything oh
they're already dead now we just sit
here and wait all the rest of them
decide to wander over here and die
man they they better be bringing these
things from alternate timelines and
multi multiple universes because I think
they're gonna run out on this plane of
existence if they keep doing it like
this
it's not a wise military strategy going
on here that's a lot of ghosts that's a
lot of ghosts hey guys do I even need to
do anything anymore I don't think so I
haven't needed to do anything for a
while spend fun guys but I'm gonna go I
know I left a few things but hey you
know it's okay it's alright I ain't
gonna worry about it okay and that's
enough I'm gonna end it at stage 33 I'm
just gonna go up to my peaceful place
that I found by this new thing here we
go this'll be nice no one can get me up
here right oh [ __ ] then get me up here
anyway but I'll leave this here I'm not
gonna like quit or anything because this
is a good game I got going on I'll see
how far it gets like I guess if you guys
want to know I'll let you know I don't
think I'll make another video about it
so small update on the situation where I
last left you off I think I was on level
32 I'm now in level 69 which i think is
a very appropriate stage to be on but
I've been playing this one for almost
500 minutes I don't even have to do
anything anymore I'm now 100% confident
that I have broken this game I don't
have to do anything and everything dies
around me I literally stand here and
here's another problem if my webcam is
not covering up the money there's
another problem with the money you may
see that I have two billion gold and you
may be like hey that's a lot of gold
that's a lot of gold see the problem is
watch my money I have negative and now I
have two million twenty eight million
sorry the numbers have gotten so big
that the system cannot comprehend
the numbers that I have it just can't
comprehend it nothing can kill me I get
to the point where I can't buy that I
can buy this now but as soon as it loops
back around I lose that money so I have
trouble buying items to even keep going
because the money is just broken the
money's broken it just is it's broken
pure and simple oh also I have 60 teddy
bears 60 which gives me I've looked this
up now because I was looking up the
statistics of it that gives me a 10%
chance to be hit ever
which means said I won't die cuz I can't
be one shot cuz these guys don't even
get the chance to do it even if the no
healing thing comes that I told you guys
about before that's not a problem
anymore because when they die I get so
much shield that it fades so slow and I
have so much health that it just doesn't
matter I didn't touch a button and they
died so I'm just gonna get this
teleporter and not what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to sacrifice myself because at
this point I this is no longer fun and I
have done so many achievements that I
have gotten myself other items to get
that would be really cool and
interesting to see in another
playthrough but I can't do anything
because I'm stuck here and I can't die
also because I have three resurrecting
teddy bears so if I die I won't even die
let your what I'll show you I'll say was
you oh wait no I can't die that way it's
only the on the one level that you get
not teleported back in yeah well
whatever hey you guys want to try to
explore with me yeah I don't know if
there's anything actually here what's
over here
Hey look oh come on now come on
oh come on I've glitched through a few
things before I have thoroughly broken
the game those are killable by the way
they're dead now yeah it's uh it's
pretty broken I'm here hey what's up and
I got a die you're gonna kill me try
nope nevermind all done
hip
I'm not doing anything I'm not touch I'm
not touching a button that's just what
happens down so the limiting factor in
this is not a matter of skill it's a
matter of boredom it's like how bored am
i willing to be in order to see this to
the end you know what I mean like that's
literally it that's the only limiting
factor there's only one way that I can
be stopped right now by the way and
that's by throwing myself in the
celestial portal which I'm going to do I
am gonna do that I just have to get to
it I think it's on the third level or
something or it's randomly sponser I
don't know
I've stopped getting lunar coins too so
that's kind of a bummer or maybe I
haven't I just can't see under the
corpses oh wait I'm done here sorry also
the the fireworks go on for so long now
that like it just cuts off when I
teleport like is it's not actually over
like every item opens an ungodly amount
of just pure unadulterated nothingness
also I have to be careful with how fast
I move by the way I didn't even mention
that because I've gotten so used to it
at this point but I have to be careful
with my movement because if I don't I
will oh well hang on I'm in combat let
me just get out and also I've already
gotten the secret in here by the way
there's a skeleton in here that tied to
an achievement if you shoot it you win
the prize there's yeah there's this
weird skeleton here and I don't know why
but there's a weird skeleton that might
be a relation like a reference to the
first game or something I have no idea
kaboom what happens if I jump down here
I don't even know nope
teleported alright cool good I'm just
gonna go ahead and hit this thing
Thanks
also I think the ghosts are a problem
because enemies stop spawning for long
periods of time because I have so many
ghosts that just like I think the game
misunderstands how many enemies are on
the field also the ghosts sometimes
mistake me for an enemy which i think is
just them trying to get revenge on how
unfair this crap really is which I get
like I totally get this these guys
actually are nice to me but some of them
just want to want to rustle my jimmies a
little bit and that's okay oh I have 26
fuel cells or something like that 25 it
doesn't matter what you do I'm just
gonna keep shooting rockets for a long
time by the way so yeah that's gonna
happen yeah I haven't stopped
I'm sorry was there someone there halt I
see your ghosts oh I see our ghosts and
shapes I don't see anything here hello
I'm good okay I'll go through then I
think it's on the third level that it
lets you actually go through through the
other thing I've also I've gotten so
many achievements I just want to be done
with this so I can see the ridiculous
statistics that are gonna show up at the
end of it and I don't know if you have
to like take this seriously in order to
do anything like get it I I don't know
if it's like a murder a lot of things
celestial kind of thing I think it just
appears out of random I'm not Arabs
insurer I haven't even gotten any lunar
items no Lunars no I don't have any
lunar coins left cuz I was just trying
to get the achievement for activating
the noot a bunch of times I just don't
know anymore it's so ridiculous like I
can't afford this I can't I can't just
can't for some reason cuz numbers don't
mean nothing no more numbers ain't real
where is everybody
hello it's awfully long they're awfully
lonely new thing shipping good day of
[ __ ] whoosh yeah everything I have to
walk without sprinting cuz I'm so fast
I'm just so ludicrously fast I can't
afford you I don't have any Luhn hours
[Music]
hey what about this is this a jumpy
puzzle oh is this is this here for
jumpin sake
oh that's cool does that mean people are
oh come on
you put that there it looks like it's
supposed to be a thing ah I can
effectively fly I have so many who poos
news oh that one hurt James alright I
get it I get it I won't do it no mo I
guess no one's gonna show up to the
party so I'll just be on my own then
let's do the thing Oh a celestial orb
appears that's good I don't know what
did that
hello why
they above me what what's that oh hi
hello can you just get in here I'm so
lazy
there's no stir stir stir and dead
I'm just got parked my butt took us
right here and wait for the celestial
thing to descend upon man destroy my
existence
seriously I could get to a hundred
stages but god I just don't want to like
I've been doing this for eight hours and
some change like that's too long
ice too long it's too long no one needs
that I don't need that you don't need
that no one needs it I'm never gonna be
able to go back to normal cuz I won't be
able to handle not being able to go with
these speeds but it's starting to get
annoying just like cuz every single tiny
ramp is fly up into the sky every single
bump point up into the sky makes no
sense
hi Birds
bah buds ah there's a celestial portal
okay let's end this pain we just have to
end this pain it has to end the I I mean
I could go on forever but god I don't
want to I can't play on are they on the
other game cuz I've been leaving this
open for like a couple days on my
computer just because I've just been so
stuck with it so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna flutter fly I've already
gotten the tome that's under there for
anyone who didn't know there's a tome
under there so I'm but I'm gonna
obliterate myself from existence because
I am a curse I should not be here I
don't deserve to live is what I'm trying
to say so I'm gonna quo okay alright it
stop just let me get on you there we go
alright obliterate Exodia obliterate
where's the real Exodia obliterate
hi am I sure
yeah what else am I gonna do Hey look
fireworks celebrate my death
wahoo what happens when you go too deep
oh I'm gone there we go good thank
goodness
Gold collected I collected way more gold
than that way more I think that's just
like the highest number it could
possibly think of one trillion nine
hundred and fifty five billion I
collected way more than that damage
taken a bunch damage dealt in one blow
eight point nine million damage dealt
total two billion kills twenty-one
thousand kill four died died four times
okay so I've got the warmonger that's
cool I don't know what that do I got the
new character I got the long road I got
her concepts to death do us part I got
so many new things so now just to
compare I have to see what the hell it's
like to come back in and I kind of want
to see what the new characters like
because I just have no idea how it's
gonna be
but how slow is this oh it's so slow
what is oh that's pretty okay oh that's
pretty
shoosh shoosh I don't even have like a
stuck non stop firing option I just have
all cool down push I missed all right so
I think this this character is like a
lot of accuracy right okay anyway I'm
not gonna play again that's not what I'm
gonna do I just wanted to see what's
like it's so slow I can't handle it
anymore I'm gonna throw myself off the
edge goodbye cruel world
skadoosh oh wait I forgot kill me kill
me I'm here gimme gimme do it oh cool
there we go and done so that's the end
of this video I don't know why I did
this
I wasted like eight hours playing this
but it was fun until it got really not
fun but yeah so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you
[Music]
you